so thank you lab roots organizers for
giving me the opportunity to speak today
about using artificial intelligence and
predictive algorithms to help advance
cancer patients identify the best
treatment options
so my name is kenny wong and i am the
chief product officer at executers
that's also my disclosure because we do
have a product that does this
in terms of my background i am a
board-certified genetic counselor so i
was previously seeing patients
at ucf ucs medical center over 12 years
ago
and then i spent the last decade in
product management in lab diagnostic
tests
where i was an early employee at council
and we sold the company to mere genetics
a few years ago and then most recently i
was also
at startup called genome smart which was
acquired by ambry genetics
where we were developing an ai software
to match patients
to the right genetic testing within a
seven-minute
questionnaire
so as i'm sure many of you are aware
physicians in general are overwhelmed
across
all industries or all verticals within
oncology
specifically there's over 1.7 million
new diagnoses per year
and also the american society of
clinical oncology
or asco project that
by 2025 there will be shortage of over 2
200 oncologists by then
in addition to that there's also a lot
of information they need to know
so there's over 600 approved or standard
treatment options
for patients cancer patients in general
and if you look at genetics specifically
there's over 400 genes
and over 23 000 actionable variants
implicated in cancer
which is mapped to target therapies
and the the guidelines are getting more
complex
year over year so in this graph what
you're seeing
is the page average page volume of nccn
guidelines or the national comprehensive
cancer network
clinical practice guidelines by disease
site
and that has increased drastically in
the last two decades
it's now hovering around 100 to 300
pages so it's a lot of information that
physicians need to know now also if you
look at it from the patient side
advanced cancer patients need help by
definition
these are patients that have exhausted
standard of care
they have less than one in two chance of
a five year survival
so by default they are often very very
scared and confused
um there's also an urgent sense of
finding
innovative therapies to help themselves
and because of the state that they're at
they're also
trying to google online look online for
um
for more information about treatments
they should consider so they also need
help in
understanding these options as well
so what we're proposing is uh what if we
can actually develop a patient-centric
position oncology platform
that's sort of what we've done here at x
cures where
you want to empower patients and their
doctors uh
with the right information so that they
could prioritize and access the best
treatment options and test
to help them beat advanced cancer
utilizing
artificial intelligence and machine
learning tools integrating public data
for information such as
clinicalchild.gov for party
proprietary knowledge from physicians in
terms of what they have done in the past
and why
and expert in sites as well so what we
want to do is create a learning system
that's efficiently incorporating results
from all patients
on all therapies at all times
if you also think about it from sort of
drug development
company standpoint as well as i'm sure
many of you
are aware the vast majority of patients
over 95 percent of patients
don't qualify or don't participate in
clinical trials
it's maybe because of um it's not near
where they currently live they're not
able to travel
to those sites or they don't meet the
inclusion exclusion criteria
and to give you a sense of the overall
market here as well
advanced cancer kills over 600 000
patients annually in the united states
so what if you can also learn and also
give
access to the 95 percent of patients
that can't
get into clinical trials what if you can
get them access to these
investigational therapies through right
to try
or manage access programs for example
and
you can still continuously learn from
them by gathering the real world data
through prospective observational
studies
and so this gives you the ability to
learn from all patients and you can then
also then give that learning back to in
order to help future patients as well
so in order to build this platform these
are the the challenges that
we have defined and have solved in order
to
build this platform to help patients so
first of all you
need to be able to understand the
patient that you're trying to help
right um you need to understand what we
call the cancer journey what is their
current
clinical situation you also need to be
able to track
longitudinal outcomes as well in order
to do that
on the bottom left side you can see our
solution
you really need to be able to build a
means to
gather real world data in a hipaa
compliant storage
a master protocol for a good clinical
practice or gcp
and also data that structured
structuring the data
in the right way so that it could be
regulatory grade and could be used for
future submissions for example
by pharma to the fda
you also then need to know the right
treatments what should be considered for
these patients
and also how to get it as well because
it's not useful to present
patients and physicians with options
that
they don't know how to get access to for
these treatments
so what you need to do is build an
options library
with a list of treatment options but
also present
why what we call the medical rationales
why
physicians historically has recommended
such um
treatment options to patients and also
how do you access these
therapies that they may be interested in
and finally you also need an engine
that can recommend the right options and
you also want to learn
from it as well so a learning system so
you're consistently learning and
improving it
and so that you could apply and put that
learning back into future patients
so you need a platform that can
understand oncology
and capture the knowledge and learn from
that as well and that's where
you we're using artificial intelligence
and machine learning
learning from experts at gathering their
insights
and incorporating it back into our
engine and also using the natural
language processing
and also predictive modeling to predict
based on the option that we would
represent
how patients would do and so you can
rank them accordingly as well which i'll
talk about
in the next slide
so just to give you a high level
overview of what we
have built so you would be able as you
can see on the left hand side
ingest uh public knowledge from
information such as clinicalchild.gov
or um literature that's published
and also on the case by case basis
patient case summaries
from medical records and then using
natural language processing
and bayesian multi-level modeling you
can then
be able to produce
treatment options and rank them as well
in addition to
the medical treatment rationale the
why we would be recommending such
treatment options for
patients and physicians to consider
and for these patients um they could be
considered by
either oncologist themselves a treating
oncologist or
molecular tumor boards and they could
then sort of give us
input in terms of whether these options
are useful
or not and we can then incorporate that
learning
back into the system to ensure that that
will help future patients as well
um so we want to gather the clinical
utility
and continuously learn from that but i
think
in the long term most importantly we
also want to gather the patient outcomes
data as well
so as a result of patients proceeding
with such recommendations
how did they do and that ultimately
would be the
source of truth in terms of which
recommendations would fare better in the
future for other patients as well
so ultimately this will be a win-win
situation where more patients are
getting more treatment options
in exchange for us at least from our
business model we are
in exchange of this no charge a no fee
service for patients they are providing
us their anonymized data for you so we
can improve it
improve the system for future patients
uh and this approach will generate more
data
which will be beneficial for both
physicians and the pharmaceutical
companies
uh so they can develop new therapies
faster each turn
through the virtuous firewall will help
improve the lives of future cancer
patients as well
and here's some initial validation data
when we were
initially in development phase of this
algorithm a while ago
so looking at the masala brain cancer
registry
uh in the last two decades of about 451
glioma patients so these are not
randomized self-reported
and based on the data that was collected
via web-based patient reported outcome
survey
we fit a bayesian multi-level model to
this virtual
trial data and we were able to
accurately predict the outcomes of
several large
faiths three these are safety and
efficacy
randomized clinical trials and so with
a little over a third of the patient
numbers that's needed for these
three set of trials so 451
compared to close to 1500
we were able to directionally
project the log survival ratios as you
can see on the right hand side
for these combinations for low mustine
and temozolomide versus
mine alone or a lomastine plus beverages
in mind
versus um lomastine
and also temozolomide plus beverages
versus uh
zolamide alone and so as you can see
here we were able to project that the
log survival ratio
directionally uh is better with the
combination of lomastine
plus tomozilla line
and here's another patient that has went
through our platform where they were
an exceptional responder to um op 201
through our managed access program or
expanded access program
so this was a pediatric patient with
h3k27n mutation
diffuse midline gliomas of the thalamus
this tends to be this is a great for um
cancer so very severe this patient was
wheelchair bound
and have already failed three lines of
therapy
and he received onto a one via our
expanded access program like i mentioned
earlier
and he has an ongoing partial response
to single agent of optional one
which led to an 81 reduction on tumor
load
from the start of antoine which was
incredible
uh the patient right now after two years
continues to do very well
uh on a single agent of onto one he's
now attending school
and can now also ride a bicycle as well
compared to when he was wheelchair bound
two years ago
and so gathering this real world data
for pharmaceutical companies are very
valuable
just to give you an example for this
brain cancer drug
about 20 of the data from
managed access programs was being used
as part of a submission
integrated analysis submission uh with
the clinical trial data
for a new drug application with the fda
um so
so the value of what we are providing
here
is not only to patients but is also
beneficial
for forward companies as well to
accelerate the drug development process
thank you